the Joker and I broke up I wanted a
fresh start but it turns out I wasn't
the only daemon got them looking for
emancipation the first trailer for DC's
birds of prey is finally here and fans
are getting their first look at Harley
Quinn's new squad but how did they all
fit together exactly we're gonna tell
you right now on the ketchup after
pretty much sealing the show in 2016
Suicide Squad which is around 27% on the
tomato meter Margot Robbie's Harley
Quinn is back in birds of prey and the
fantabulous emancipation of one Harley
Quinn can't wait to type that into my
smart TV four years after the events of
Suicide Squad Harley has left the Joker
and Batman has disappeared leaving
Gotham City unprotected so in this film
Harley teams up with a group of female
heroes called the birds of prey which
includes jurnee smollett Belles black
canary mary elizabeth winstead Huntress
and detective Renee Montoya played by
Rosie Perez they basically all joined
forces to help save a young girl from an
evil crime lord aka Black Mass played by
you and McGregor so in the comics he
gets sadistic pleasure from the act of
torture and has a fixation with masks
now we didn't see a black mask in the
trailer but hey who wants to cover up
that million-dollar smile the new
trailer shows much of what fans have
grown to love about Harley lots of
bright colors funny one-liners and the
adorable innocence that tries to mask
her ruthlessness and ability to kick
some serious ass and not to mention
Harley's hyenas
and fans are so far cautiously
optimistic about it
so one user on Twitter said this looks
way better than I thought it would count
me in with another adding very very
intrigued by how nutty this looks margot
robbie looks like she's having a
freaking blast cannot wait to see more
of you and mcgregor but the Bern the
Suicide Squad left on fans is still
actually lingering with comments like I
worry this birds-of-prey trailer has the
same vibe and empty promises as that
thrilling and perfect Suicide Squad
Comic Con trailer but I have chosen hope
hope in all caps no one gives the we are
beyond that the rated our film comes out
February 7th of next year and was
written by Christina Hudson who did the
bumblebee movie and the upcoming
background movie and it's directed by
Cathy Ann who is now the second woman to
direct a film for the DC EU so Wonder
Woman's patty Jenkins was the first and
she's also the first Asian woman to
direct a superhero movie so shout out to
Cathy other cast members include Chris
Messina as villain Victor Zsasz and
comedian Ali Wong will play someone
working alongside Perez's Renee Montoya
in Gotham law enforcement and it's worth
noting that in the comics Renee is one
of the DC universes most prominent gay
characters so we'll see if that carries
over to the movie as far as what this
means for the future of the DC EU while
the prospect of Black Canary making an
appearance is really exciting because it
lays the possible groundwork to include
her mentor Wildcat as well as her
longtime boyfriend Green Arrow and other
characters that could pop up in this or
down the road include katana Hawkgirl
Catwoman and poison ivy although some of
those could be saved for a possible
Gotham City sirens movie which has
supposedly been in development for a
while now
but it's time to kick it over to you are
you excited for birds of prey were you
hoping for Harley to be working alone or
are you hoping to see more birds of prey
and we know Harley and mr. J just broke
up but do you want a joaquin phoenix
margot robbie mashup you know you
thought about it sound off below with
all your feelings and then we were done
with that make sure to subscribe to this
channel and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss any future episodes as
always thanks for watching the ketchup
i'm mask press and i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]